bonsoir monsieur lamoureux
alors comment vous expliquez vous ce qui
se passe actuellement chez rogers
c'est très difficile explique exaucé
c'est annie pas comprendre
quand même
c'est important une chicane de famille
dans une entité comme ça la famille roy
jazz est très importante en ontario
depuis longtemps
cuias famille radieuse et très important
mais dont la structure réseau commun y
contrôler la compagnie rogers avec une
fiducie qui contrôlent 98 pour ça je
pense des actions votantes
ils ont que les présidents du conseil à
penser que son rôle et que lui avait
légué pouvoir pour laisser aller
si haut de pdg mais par contre le
président du conseil il faut pas oublier
faut pas oublier que
ces jeux c'est un amour de mam du
conseil y'a pas de pouvoirs plus
puissants que les autres membres du
conseil il ne sera qu'un vrai donc
monsieur
roger été rabroués par la conseil qui
comprend de ces salles et sa mère exact
sa mère s'est opposé à lui ses deux
soeurs se sont opposés à lui donc dans
une entreprise familiale comme ça et où
il ya une fiducie familiale la famille
doit se parler quand même est-ce que
c'est pas inquiétant de se retrouver
dans cette situation là dans une entité
dans une entreprise aussi grosse que
rogers
d'après moi c'est une
chien de famille et on va voir comment
ça va se régler je ne crois pas que ça
perfetti l'accord pays à long terme mais
à court terme il peut avoir des impôts
ouais il peut avoir des impacts donc un
type d'impact qui pourrait y avoir
est-ce que la réputation de rogers est
en jeu
maintenant que la réputation quand on
voit quelque chose comme ça c'est
évident que sa réputation telle peu
entachée
[Musique]
le pdg ici le changement un conseil se
faisait le pdg est prêt à démissionner
et dit que la mesure dite l'équipe de
gestion aussi
démissionné donc je peux voir les
impacts du recours est ce que le pdg
fait bien son travail est ce qu'un enjeu
par rapport au pdg joe natale et à la
tête de rogers qui je le rappelle est la
plus grande entreprise de
télécommunications au canada est ce
qu'un enjeu sur son travail à lui
il s'enferme très bel ouvrage le conseil
a en majorité à approuver ce type de
travail qu'il faisait fort souvenez que
monsieur rares joueurs j'étais celui qui
était recherché chez telus c'est leur
petit très cher parce qu'il y avait
quelque chose la compétition avec telus
donc c'est surprenant de voir que
monsieur n'zi aujourd'hui
c'est ali est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un
lien avec la transaction qui est en
train de faire c'est-à-dire
l'acquisition de chaque communication
par rogers non rouge du tréport je ne
crois pas que lille et skoda
les mails
et il n'offrira date et nous émis aucun
communiqué de presse de sans savoir
qu'il n'était pas opportun de du travail
et monsieur nathalie est ce que ça remet
en question la transaction les chicanes
de rogers au passé
je dors je pense une bonne transaction
mais le chien à l'autre à long terme on
ne sait pas ce qui peut arriver
adapta jamais chaud à prouver et tout
quoi de ce qu'ils se parlent se
déchaînent familiale nous on veut pas
s'en mêler mais on peut voir on verra ce
qui se passe et comment ça va se passer
au conseil d'administration parce que
monsieur rogers reste quand même dans le
conseil d'administration est ce que
c'est ce que sa va être fonctionnel
sap et fonctionnel mais ça va être
c'est difficile de voir des résolutions
par ces délais limités comme souvent ça
arrive un conseil de convaincre le
conseil est divisé en deux clans il
s'agit savoir lequel va gagner et parce
qu'il y aura un gagnant il ya des gens
qui vont finir par partir c'est ça il ya
des gens qui ont fini par passer de la
whey est une mesure injuste pour ceux
turicum mais comme perdre un à noter
mais ouverte est ce que est ce que
l'entreprise doit revoir sa gouvernance
il vient bientôt comme un investisseur
institutionnel
on n'était pas content de gouvernance
faut pas oublier que 92% les votes sont
contredits par la famille mais tous les
investisseurs savent seul lorsqu'il se
lève c'est un world girls aldata pas été
un obstacle mais on verra ce qui est ce
qui va se passer dans le futur avec
votre longue expérience monsieur
lamoureux avez vous déjà vu une affaire
comme ça
moi je n'ai jamais vu une affaire comme
ça et j'ai parlé à mes amis avocats qui
est très expérimenté qui est qu'ils
aient participé à plusieurs de ces
chiens de là il me dit qu'il n'avait
jamais jamais vu quelque chose comme ça
et est même déjà un processus qu'on voit
actuellement donc c'est toute une saga
il y aura peut-être un film de séjour
sur la famille rogers
exactement merci monsieur lamoureux
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir mais
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh